ich habe mir mal die mühe gemacht und
kosten aufgerechnet wohnkosten bei uns
sind 1200 euro im monat
strom wasser müll habe ich mal mit 220
euro ausgerechnet heizkosten kommen auf
175 versicherungen das sind doch nicht
mal alle enthalten zum beispiel
krankenversicherung für tochter und so
weiter bei 850 euro telefon internet tv
120 euro und traurig genug herr scholz
lasse die aktuellen benzinpreise nicht
wissen geschlagen bei uns mit 250 euro
im monat zu wenden vorsorge auch ein
wichtiger punkt 800 euro lebensmittel
sie sagen sie sind nicht teurer geworden
wir sind dafür lädt auch etwas
bescheiden haben wir mal mit 500 euro
angesetzt dann braucht man noch kosten
für reparaturen sonstiges 100 euro da
bin ich schon über 4000 euro im monat
und jetzt sollte auch noch die co2
steuer kommen benzin noch teurer heizen
noch teurer
ich habe mir mal eine gegenrechnung
gemacht zum beispiel aus dem jahr 2016
laden meine kosten noch bei 3.100 euro
und das war ja dann bald 30 prozent
steigerung in den letzten viereinhalb
fünf jahren
ich weiß nicht ob das sein kann das
alles noch teurer wird und ich fordere
eigentlich die politik auf und auch
sieben sie kanzler werden möchten dass
die kosten in deutschland unter
kontrolle bleiben ich denke nicht dass
sein kann dass alles nur nach oben geht
deswegen geht einmal vorschläge was man
machen kann nicht nur immer anheben
sondern die kosten einfach mal unter
kontrolle halten